a video game meets Toy Story you know
I'm into this wreck-it Ralph
so wreck-it Ralph is the story of Ralph
he's a villain inside an arcade game in
which he beats the hell out of this
building and then the player plays as a
character named fix-it Felix who fixes
the building after Ralph's Rexha and
Ralph's doesn't want to be a villain
anymore this movie is like I said kind
of like Toy Story you know in Toy Story
when the humans weren't looking the toys
would interact and talk with each other
that's what this is like when the lights
go out the arcade closes down all the
little videogame characters talk to each
other and I like that this is like the
Toy Story of the new generation now
although there are still action figures
more kids play video games than play
with action figure so when I say this
movie is Toy Story for the new
generation I really do mean that now
what that record Ralph was gonna be cool
from the get-go cuz I was like I can't
wait to see all the little video game
references they have in there we saw in
the trailer you got Clyde the little
pac-man goes you got Bowser and bison
that kind of stuff is really cool and
that kind of stuff is in wreck-it Ralph
but it's not the point of wreck-it Ralph
record Ralph is actually a solid movie
about Ralph that really surprised me
it's not the video game showcase I
thought it was gonna be much as I love
my video game crossover references I
will take a solid movie over that stuff
that's just made up if you're a video
gamer you're gonna find all the video
game Easter eggs and they're gonna have
you laugh and you're gonna be pointing
your friends out dude look at that look
at that is that the thing from joust
holy yeah they take it back old
school lot in this movie so you have
that aspect for the gamers but it is a
good movie in and of itself I thought he
was gonna go game hopping to a bunch of
different worlds he actually goes to two
so when he ends up in this one world
which is I can only describe as candy
land meets Mario Kart I was kind of
bummed out because in the trailer I was
like I hope the whole movie doesn't
doesn't just take place in that one
place life for all intents and purposes
it really does now when I met Sarah
Silverman's character I was like this
girl annoys me I understand she's
supposed to be annoying because she
obviously is annoying to Ralph's a
character like this is supposed to be
annoying to us if it's annoying to route
that's how we're going to connect to him
but have an annoyance be the thing that
we see eye to eye with Ralph on it's
really tricky because you're annoyed
with a character in the movie that's
just not going away anytime soon however
it does end up working out in this movie
when she annoys the out of Ralph
she annoys the out of you and then
when you're like
all right I got you you almost feel like
a douchebag for thinking she was
annoying props to the movie pulling that
off so I was enjoying this movie even
though there's a section about in the
middle where the movie kind of slows
down a bit but then the movie does
something it hits an emotional tone that
I didn't expect there are a couple
moments in this movie where it gets
quite a few points for being just a
little more emotional than it had to be
so I expected to see some videogame
throw back some video game references I
did get that not as much as I wanted
however I got a deeper movie that I was
expecting which is actually the best
animation of the year that I've seen
looked over the animations that I've
reviewed it is the best and is a great
first chapter to what could be a new
franchise which could be the next toy
story I really mean it because wreck-it
Ralph is awesome tacular seriously
though some of these video game
references that they do have in the
movie they're good so what is your
favorite old-school game I want to see
how many old-school gamers we got in
here whatever it is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you